hola qué tal cómo están pues
efectivamente soy alex toledo y estoy
muy contento de estar aquí con todos
ustedes porque hoy les voy a hablar de
un monstruo que afortunadamente nos
persigue durante toda nuestra vida y su
nombre es el cambio
qué pasaría si de una vez por todas
recibiéramos abrazar el cambio
pero como lo hacemos cuántos de ustedes
han atravesado alguna vez un cambio que
se siente tan devastador tan real y tan
profundo que pareciera el fin del mundo
y estoy hablando de cambios realmente
importantes de esos cambios que llegan a
moverte todo el panorama que llegan a
moverte hasta la raíz más profunda y que
te hacen replantear tu sistema de
creencias todo lo que te han inculcado
el concepto que tenías de ti hasta tus
planes a futuro uno de los cambios más
grandes e importantes que yo he
atravesado en mi vida fue hace ya
algunos años cuando me tocó vivir con mi
familia una muy fuerte situación que nos
obligó a movernos y que nos puso a
replantearnos el panorama y cambió
nuestro estilo de vida yo acababa de
terminar la preparatoria entré al primer
semestre en la universidad pero tuve que
salirme porque me vio obligado a buscar
trabajo para ayudar a solventar algunos
gastos y con la preparatoria hecha pues
se imaginarán que los trabajos que
encontré no eran bien pagados así que en
esa época más por necesidad que por
gusto me obligué casi a escribir mis dos
primeras obras
un par de cuentos para niños
que después de buscar muchas
oportunidades logré hacer que una
editorial me publicara con ese dinero
que no fue mucho y ahora que pasaron los
años me doy cuenta de lo importante que
es leer los contratos pude solventar
algunos gastos de mi familia y fue como
una pequeñísima bocanada de aire fresco
pero no fue suficiente así que seguí
buscando y afortunadamente gracias a que
pude publicar estos dos libros se me
abrieron las puertas en el área de
marketing digital de un importante
empresa transnacional de refrescos
esa empresa me contrató y el sueldo que
me dieron fue muy bueno así que pude
ayudar a mi familia durante una
temporada más a solventar la vida ya
seguir produciendo la y finalmente la
tormenta pasó todo se normalizó mi
hermano y yo regresamos a la escuela
justo cuando pensamos que nunca más
íbamos a tocar una aula y fue una
temporada muy dolorosa fue muy solitaria
y muy amarga pero esa vivencia nos
obligó a hacer más arios y más fuertes y
porque les cuento esto porque fue
gracias a esa situación que yo entendí
lo que era abrazar al monstruo del
cambio porque esa situación de escasez
que viví es lo que me hace estar aquí
hoy frente a ustedes y yo no sería la
persona que soy hoy si no hubiera vivido
eso porque esa situación me obligó a
descubrir mis talentos mis habilidades y
la capacidad que tenía para salir
adelante que es la capacidad que hoy me
hace dedicarme a lo que me dedico que es
ayudar a otras personas a tener mejores
relaciones interpersonales a curarse el
corazón o como yo digo curarse las
emociones
y justamente es esos cambios de los que
hoy quiero hablarles de esos cambios
profundos que nos obligan a
transformarnos luego de mucho tiempo y
de cierta edad nos damos cuenta que
hemos atravesado muchos cambios que
hemos estado inmersos en los cambios y
el primer gran cambio que experimentamos
en nuestra vida es pasar de estar dentro
del vientre a estar afuera y ese aunque
no lo recordamos es el primer gran
cambio el primer momento de
transformación y como bebés tenemos que
enfrentarlo luego seguimos caminando en
el sendero de nuestra experiencia humana
y nos damos cuenta que el cambio es
constante y que la vida realmente está
sumergida en cambios cambios como por
ejemplo nos crece el pelo nos crecieron
los dientes nos estiramos pero también
conforme vamos avanzando hay otro tipo
de cambios más profundos que nos hacen
mover muchas cosas a nivel interno que
se van hasta la raíz cambios que nos
hacen poner en práctica una cosa muy
importante que es la resiliencia y la
resiliencia es la capacidad que tenemos
las personas
para sobreponernos a los peores hechos
de nuestra vida a las situaciones
adversas un cambio de casa un cambio de
trabajo un cambio de círculo social
inclusive cambios como un cambio de
estado civil un matrimonio un divorcio
una ruptura y también cambios tan
dolorosos y tan trascendentales como una
muerte
yo quiero preguntarle a todos los
asistentes
quienes ya que se han enfrentado al
cambio que provoca perder a alguien que
aman pueden levantar la mano
bien gracias
pues para todos aquellos que no
levantaron la mano les tengo un spoiler
en algún momento de la vida ustedes van
a perder a alguien que aman y se van a
tener que enfrentar ese cambio y después
en otro momento de su vida van a ser
ustedes los que van a ser la pérdida
para alguien que los ama y esa persona
tendrá que adaptarse a ese cambio sin
ustedes como ven nuestra vida ha estado
llena de cambios constantemente nos
hemos movido en el agitado mar de los
cambios entonces porque nos dan tanto
miedo porque le tenemos tanta aversión a
transformarnos con los cambios la
explicación más acertada que tenemos
hasta el momento es gracias a la
neuropsicología que nos ha enseñado que
el cerebro es una máquina perfecta que
está creada para resolver para
estructurar para enfrentar problemas y
el cerebro trabaja dentro de esa
cuadratura pero esa cuadratura entre en
un choque y hace cortocircuito con el
cambio porque el cambio para el cerebro
representa la posibilidad de encontrar
peligro frente a aquello que no conoce y
que pone en amenaza nuestra estabilidad
entonces porque nos cuesta trabajo
sabiendo esto porque nos cuesta trabajo
aceptar todo esto volviendo a la
pregunta anterior yo mismo me enfrenté a
ese cuestionamiento cuando me enteré que
lo que me hacía temerle al cambio era la
versión que me provocaba y la
resistencia que yo tenía a la
incertidumbre y mi necesidad de querer
controlarla y esto que les digo lo pude
comprobar tiempo después cuando me
convertí en terapeuta con muchos de mis
pacientes que venían la terapia conmigo
para pedirme ayuda porque se había
presentado un cambio en su vida que
había venido a conflictuar les la
existencia en todos los casos lo que
pude observar es que les había pasado
exactamente lo mismo que a mí la
incertidumbre se había presentado en sus
vidas y había venido a amenazar su
estabilidad y sentirnos amenazados en
nuestra estabilidad y seguridad es algo
que detestamos porque como humanos
estamos acostumbrados a que nuestra vida
sea lo más fácil y cómoda posible y el
cambio es todo menos comodidad seguridad
y estabilidad
entonces cuando yo me pude sobreponer a
tener que controlar la incertidumbre a
aceptarla y fluir con ella me replanteé
la pregunta que podemos hacer las
personas para que esto de la
incertidumbre nos deje de causar rechazo
y aversión y la respuesta la encontré
también con mis pacientes en donde
descubrí que la clave para aceptar la
incertidumbre era aceptarla soltarla y
avanzar una vez que se tuviera que ir
esto suena muy fácil decirlo pero la
verdadera tarea es llevarla a la
práctica lo cual resulta más simple
cuando entendemos que todo en la vida
está en constante cambio que a parte de
la muerte lo único seguro que tenemos en
la vida es el cambio entonces cuando
entendemos que el cambio es parte de la
vida todo resulta más sencillo nuestro
apego constante a querer tener seguridad
y certidumbre en nuestra vida es lo que
hace que el cambio provoque sufrimiento
porque queremos a toda costa siempre
estar seguros y el cambio es la manera
más rápida que tiene la vida para
convertirnos en la persona que tenemos
que ser que estamos destinados a hacer
no solo para nosotros mismos sino
también para los demás es la forma más
eficaz de poder encontrar en que tenemos
que trabajar qué podemos hacer y que
podemos trabajar para mejorar
y claro que siempre vamos a poder elegir
no avanzar con el cambio siempre vamos a
poder elegir quedarnos sentados y hacer
que el cambio pase frente a nuestros
ojos pero hacer eso es muy peligroso
porque cuando elegimos que el cambio
pase frente a nuestros ojos lo que
estamos eligiendo es una terrible verdad
y esa verdad es que después de cierto
tiempo vamos a llegar a una edad en
donde se nos van a venir encima el peso
de todos los años que vivimos y ahí nos
vamos a sentir desdichados y miserables
porque va a venir el enojo el reproche
va a venir el arrepentimiento y entonces
nos vamos a convertir en nuestros
propios verdugos lo que vamos a hacer es
torturar nos a nosotros mismos con el
famoso y horrendo que hubiera pasado sí
qué hubiera pasado si lo hubiera hecho
si lo hubiera intentado si me hubiera
animado si me hubiera arriesgado si
hubiera si hubiera si hubiera si hubiera
y no lo vamos a saber porque lo único
que pasó frente a nuestros ojos fue eso
la vida
y como en lo personal es es un escenario
que a mí me aterra terriblemente ya
ustedes también debería de darles mucho
miedo más que el cambio
quiero compartir con ustedes
tres herramientas muy sencillas pero
sumamente eficaces para comprender cómo
es que podemos trabajar con el cambio
número 1 paciencia porque la paciencia
porque la mente y las emociones tienen
su proceso y su tiempo para procesar las
cosas es un gran y terrible error querer
atravesar un cambio con presión y
ansiedad porque lo único que vamos a
hacer es limitar nuestra propia
capacidad para de manera consciente
poner atención a lo que ese cambio nos
está obligando a trabajar así que ante
el cambio lo mejor es dejar que se
instale y que se quede el tiempo que se
tenga que quedar los primeros que
tenemos que ser pacientes con nosotros
mismos somos nosotros número 2 confianza
sé que es muy difícil confiar cuando hay
incertidumbre de por medio pero que
creen por eso se llama confianza es como
en una relación de pareja mucha gente
viene a mi consultorio y me dicen sabe
que sabes que álex es que necesito
confiar en mi pareja pero solamente
hasta que sepa todo de él o de ella y
entonces la cara de decepción viene
viene a ellos cuando les digo no no
necesita saber todo de tu pareja para
confiar porque por eso es confianza lo
mismo pasa con el cambio no necesitamos
saber cómo se va a desarrollar la
situación para confiar que ese cambio se
está presentando nuestra
por una razón alguna vez un maestro muy
sabio me dijo que todos los cambios que
pasan en nuestra vida son para nuestro
bien aunque en el momento no lo veamos
pero eventualmente ese cambio va a pasar
y cuando pase vamos a ver la verdadera
razón por la que ese cambio tenía que
llegar a nuestra vida así que cuando el
cambio llegue y se presente con nosotros
hay que dejarlo porque seguramente ese
cambio nos obligará a trabajar ya poner
atención en algo importante y
eventualmente sabiendo eso también
sabremos que el cambio va a pasar y
número 3 aceptación la aceptación no es
resignación porque la resignación
significa no hacer nada quedarse de
brazos cruzados la resignación es
impotencia la aceptación viene pegado
con la frustra la aceptación a la
frustración con la tolerancia que
tenemos a la frustración y la tolerancia
a la frustración se trabaja cuando
comprendemos que hay cosas que no
podemos cambiar que hay cosas que
simplemente son porque tienen que ser
y cuando dejamos de luchar contra ello
entonces quitamos esa resistencia y
entonces nos permitimos hacer que el
cambio deje de doler porque lo que sí
podemos controlar de nosotros es la
manera en la que reaccionamos ante esos
cambios eso sí depende de nosotros y eso
puede ser la diferencia entre el dolor y
el sufrimiento que provoca el cambio y
que es el sufrimiento el sufrimiento es
la prolongación voluntaria
e indefinida del dolor y hay mucha gente
que decide quedarse estacionada en el
sufrimiento aunque el dolor ya haya
pasado pero quedarnos en el sufrimiento
alargar ese dolor al punto de
convertirlo en sufrimiento y ser
negligente con nosotros mismos es auto
violentarnos y no es justo con todo esto
lo que trato de decirles y con lo que
trato de enseñarles y quiero invitarlos
es a que acepten el cambio como parte de
nuestra vida porque el cambio es parte
de nuestra naturaleza porque el cambio
es movimiento y la vida es movimiento el
universo mismo está en movimiento
constante porque nosotros entonces
tendríamos que estar exentos del cambio
negar el cambio es negar nuestra
naturaleza es negarnos la oportunidad de
convertirnos en la mejor versión de
nosotros mismos y eso también es muy
injusto como dijo el famoso escritor
haruki murakami japonés nominado
muchísimas veces al premio nobel de
literatura y esto es bellísimo y
entonces entrarás en la tormenta
y eventualmente saldrás también de esa
tormenta pero no vas a estar muy seguro
de si la tormenta acabó realmente lo que
sí es seguro es que no vas a ser la
misma persona que cuando entró a la
tormenta y de eso se trata la tormenta
de transformarnos así que de nosotros
depende si abrazamos al tormentoso
monstruo del cambio para bien o para mal
y también hay que tener en cuenta otra
cosa que la vida todo es impermanente
nada dura todo pasa así que si alguien
en este momento de su vida se está
encontrando en una etapa de cambios o el
monstruo del cambio está tocando a su
puerta abran le inviten lo a pasar
agradezcan lo y es más inviten le un
café para que ese monstruo del cambio se
quede todo el tiempo que tenga que
quedarse porque ese monstruo del cambio
quizá es el cambio que tanto pedían para
evolucionar y no se acuerdan y cuando
ese monstruo se vaya verán que
efectivamente les dejó regalos que les
van a ayudar a ser mejor persona y van a
entender por qué tenía que llegar ese
monstruo
yo lo he comprobado y estoy seguro que
muchos y muchas aquí lo han comprobado
también cuántos de ustedes serían las
personas que son hoy si no hubieran
atravesado toda la cantidad de cambios
que han atravesado en sus vidas
seguramente no serían las personas que
son hoy así que el cambio es crecimiento
es evolución antes de finalizar me
gustaría muchísimo regalarles justamente
esta frase que ahora se ha convertido en
mi filosofía de vida y que quiero
compartir con ustedes deja que llegue
deja que duela deja que pase deja que
sane y deja que pase y entonces cuando
pase ahora si te vas a dar cuenta que
estás listo o lista para darte el
permiso de seguir continuando pero esta
vez más fuerte con más sabiduría y mucho
más feliz y entonces te vas a dar cuenta
que el monstruo del cambio en realidad
no era un monstruo y que todo parte con
ese monstruo
era de hecho lo mejor que te pudo haber
pasado en la vida y eso queridos amigos
y amigas eso es abrazar el cambio porque
pues porque en la vida todo pasa todo
cambia y todo vuelve a empezar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]